we are back to work Templeton hello you  beautiful baby car bosses brother are  they always this friendly I can't have  my own brother ignorant to the art of  business it's embarrassing I make sure  the world loves babies more than puppies  more than kittens what's the threat what  cats don't play by rules fate of the  company's in your mashed potato hands  don't blow it just kidding of course you  win what's up  this meeting is making me uncomfortable  what do we do I'm gonna bag the tiger  [Music]  this is my job on the line you made a  choice to join a family we can fix this  what if you broke nothing leave it on  the gas just spoon star for Stacey  in fairness early cat thought of it  first Odie you can't kill what you can't  see  time to go invisible mommy is a dirty  liar  [Music]  you